yes it is mike tomlin and we have that
running back right here a great
combination of
size and power and flat out speed he's
the nfl's current rushing leader member
tennessee titans derek henry der good
afternoon how are you buddy
doing good how are y'all doing doing
good
mike tomlin trying to butter you up a
little bit as we get ready for the game
on sunday
what have you seen about the steelers
defense that has gotten your attention
as you get ready for the game
um you know i've known by a silver
defense it's also a little kid
you know watching football they've
always had guys that are stout big up
front um physical linebackers that are
fast and
guys in the secondary are willing to you
know make tackles
uh you know get get turnovers so
you know they got a great defense guys
are playing great together collectively
um they're they're physical and um
they're doing a great job this year so
it's gonna be a big matchup a big game
and um
i'll look forward to you know playing
against those guys
derek the steelers and oilers back in
the day played some huge games and the
oilers of course had the greatest
running back in your organization's
history in earl campbell i'm just
curious you've been compared to earl
campbell a lot
have you seen any videos old videos of
earl campbell and
and what do you think of that comparison
yeah
it's so funny when i was a kid i still
watch nfl network a lot
and they used to have like countdowns of
the greatest backs in nfl history you
know
i know i i know a little bit about
brought running backs out of a freight
position but
it was it was something like earl
campbell um came on the screen i was
like oh my god
just running through everybody everybody
was just falling
he had big legs everybody was bouncing
off of them and you know i was just
in awe whenever i you know seen that
that clip and got to meet him got to
talk to him a couple times
um we came to organization i seem to
make some signing so it's just pretty
cool to see a guy that you
you know you grew up looking highlights
and hearing about
all the greatness and then getting to
meet my personal very cool
well derek you're creating your own
highlight reel now especially with the
stiff arms and we saw the one last
tuesday night everyone did
of josh norman from your perspective
though is it more gratifying when you
get to stiff arm someone
or when you see a guy make that business
decision
to get out of your way
um i think to me it's just me um
because i work on things that i do
without a lot all the time in practice
and you know because
puts heavy emphasis on on things that
you know
that we're good at so we can be even
better so i work on the stiff arm
catching the ball just oh that
i want to improve on so it's just to me
it's i i'm happy that it actually worked
and i was able to use my advantage and
you know if defender wants to go high
and
wants to try my stiff arm then i'm
definitely going to use it
derek you led the league in rushing last
season you're leading it in rushing this
season ladainian thomason is the last
guy to do it in back-to-back years in
2006 and 2007.
he won the mvp award in 2006 the only
other running back to win it since then
is adrian peterson you think it's time
that we start putting you in that
conversation with all those quarterbacks
we always talk about
oh well lt that's one of my i plays all
the time man i'm a
big lt fan watching since i was a kid
and all the
you know all the mvp mvp conversations
um you know
um just focus on what i need to do to
help my team man and
you know just keep working keep focused
on getting better you know i don't
really get caught up in
all that hype you know off of one game
um
i just want to focus on what i can do
better to help my team
um us continue to grow as a team and um
keep moving forward as the season goes
on
you know derek as your career has gone
on you've gotten a greater and greater
workload
every year first two years you shared
touches with demarco murray
now you're on pace for 393 rushing
attempts what's your ideal
total attempts per game and for a full
season
um i really look at the numbers and you
know
what's projecting or how many carrots
i'm getting you know like i said
i'm all about team man so if that's what
it takes for me to help my team win or
you know
for me to have an impact on the season
to help us get where we want to go then
i'm all for it man you know anything i
can do to help the team i'm always
i'm always i'm always with it you know i
know my teammates know that my coaches
know that so
whatever it takes whatever it takes it's
always the mentality
derek mike just mentioned that you did
share those carries early in your career
with demarco murray he's now a
college running backs coach obviously a
big time assistant coach i'm just
curious if you
learned anything from him early in your
career
and and just sitting back and watching
sometimes on the sideline
did that save you from some of the wear
and tear maybe early in your career
um yeah man marco was a real pro
came to work every day um very smart um
a blue collar guy and um you know
king came to work and approached him
like like a business
each and every day so just watching him
you know i learned a lot from him you
know those uh
those first two years and you know him
being the college coach is no shock he
knows the game
in and out it's a very smart guy and um
can be a big
impact on guys coming to college um from
high school to help them
you know get where they want to go so i
can't think of nobody better to you know
be a running back culture how much
knowledge he has for the game
and um definitely you know not having a
big heavy load the first two years of
you know help any running back just so
the position is so physical and um you
know
i would say definitely helped me you
know by those first two years not
getting heavy load
derek joins us today thanks to dr teals
epsom soap
salts salt let me try that again dr
teals epsom salt
soaks how does that help you after a
game like the one you had on
sunday uh helps a lot um
that's one of the things i use to get my
body back under me you know after a game
especially like y'all mentioned getting
heavy workloads so
i use as much as i can you know try to
soak
uh twice or three times a week with the
epsom salt um just just sitting in the
bathtub
and in warm water and just letting it
you know work work for my body recharge
my body get my muscles back
back recover and um whole body back
recovered so
that's something i use weekly um week
out the week
during the season you know um because
you know running backs we get uh you
know a body
uh takes hits a lot so i use epsom salt
dr till's
is the best out there so i definitely
recommend if anybody
hasn't used it to go out there and use
it because it definitely gets your body
back right you'll feel good
derek you guys had the the covet
outbreak obviously and
you seem to get through that just fine
you came out and played great despite
having a little practice time
did that affect you or your teammates at
all as your guys
can't practice and you're just doing the
virtual meetings
well no i think we all just wanted to
get back the ball
um you know just doing all the things
that we needed to do to get back in the
building get back together
and get back to playing football and um
and
that's all i was waiting on just working
out um doing what we could
until we got the word that we all get
back together practice and get ready for
preparation for a game and you know just
all
do all those things until we're able to
get back out there and play
derek we're down to the last minute so
we really appreciate some of your time
today and we appreciate dr teal's epsom
salt soxy i got it right that time
i got to ask you this before i let you
go though you were there when ryan
tannehill joined the team as a backup
comparing what he was when he walked
through the door to where he is now what
changes have you seen
um you know i think whenever he came
he just approached you know practice
or the preparation as a starter um
we know what what what he's done in
miami so
we know he had that type of ability and
then from the time that he
you know he came in and took over for
the position
just been a general like i said earlier
in the interview at the sunday he's been
spectacular
just telling guys we need to be
communicating
um uh we see the throws we see the plays
he makes
in the game and you know i think that's
where the mvp conversation needs to
start
but ryan tannehill well derek we
appreciate it maybe we'll be co-mvps
ryan tannehill and derek henry the way
you guys are going i wouldn't rule out
anything
again thanks to you thanks to dr thiel's
epsom salt soak
and good luck this weekend with the
pittsburgh steelers coming
to coming to town it should be a great
game yes sir thank you thank y'all for
having me y'all take care
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports